I'm purchasing an office chair online
and they're asking me if I want to leave
a tip 25 20 18% tip for what tipping
culture has gone way too far nowadays
you're asked for a tip nearly everywhere
are we tipping at drive-throughs 15
20% on a sweatshirt purchase if you're
fustrated you're not alone a survey by
bank rate found that a third of people
are annoyed by those pre-entered tip
screens
and think tipping culture has gotten out
of control businesses and cities have
tried to move away from tipping but I
don't see any kind of a future where
tipping completely goes away that's Dr
Mike Lynn a Cornell psychologist who
studies consumer Behavior I've done more
research on tipping than anybody else
and he'll help us explain why the us
became so dependent on tipping why it
seems to be everywhere now and why we're
probably not getting rid of
it tipping really became popular after
the Civil War when formerly enslaved
black Americans went into service
positions like waiters and railroad
Porters and the railroad industry
deliberately paid them low wages on
account of their ability to work for
tips and arguably it was this influx of
service workers who were receiving low
wages that contributed to the growth of
tipping by the early 1900s as minimum
wages were being established tipped
workers were initially excluded until
1966 when tipped workers were given
their own minimum wage it was raised to
$2.13 in 1991 where it stayed ever since
consumers in this country are aware that
servers make a substandard minimum wage
and that that contributes to their
willingness and desire to tip them some
states require employers to pay just
that tipped minimum wage to workers
where some states like California and
Minnesota require them to pay workers
the full minimum wage and then tips are
added onto that and those minimum wages
affect how people tip I was able to get
data from uh credit card payment system
providers uh on charge sales and charge
tips in restaurants across States and
what I find is the smaller the wages
servers are paid the higher the
percentage tip in other words he found
that people know their tips are how
workers get paid so they tip more when
they know workers are being paid less in
that same bank R survey 41% of people
said businesses should pay their
employees better rather than relying so
much on tips but in practice people
don't like that I've done the research
where I give people hypothetical menus
one where they have regular prices and
at the bottom it says a customary tip of
15 to 20% is appreciated one where they
say tipping is not allowed you can't tip
but their menu prices are 15% higher he
then asked people how expensive they
thought the restaurant was people
overwhelmingly thought the menu with the
15% higher prices was more expensive
than a menu where they would tip 15% or
more anyway other menus that stated an
18 or 15% gratuiti would be
automatically added were also viewed as
more expensive we're not rational we're
cognitive misers we don't like to add
all of the factors together and make
logical rational comparisons we do quick
and dirty heuristics it's called price
partitioning
you see it with hotel listings or
concert tickets with all kinds of fees
tacked on at the end partitioning prices
often makes things seem less expensive
than if you were to build all of the
cost and be upfront in one big price
which is one of the reasons you're
seeing tipping just about everywhere now
postco we've experienced inflation and
full
employment and service
establishments have to compete for
employees which means paying them more
but paying them more requires them to
raise prices and customers are already
facing inflation and and so what's a
business to do and I think that tipping
is a way to address that problem a good
faith effort on the part of of
businesses to say I need to pay my
employees more but I don't want to raise
my prices too much on you guys so are
people really tipping 20% for
self-service or counter service
according to that bank rate study the
vast majority of people are still always
tipping servers or weight staff at a
sitdown restaurant from what we've
learned from Dr Lyn studies probably in
part because they know those workers
depend on tips but when getting coffee
not as many when picking up takeout even
fewer so just because someone's asking
for a tip doesn't mean it's customary
doesn't mean everyone else is giving the
new technology kind of hides from us
what the actual behavioral Norms are
tipping was seen as unamerican even in
the 1800s in the 1900s polls showed
Americans wanting to get rid of tipping
today 2third of Americans have a
negative view of tipping but it's so
ingrained into American price models and
policies that tipping is probably here
to stay but where and how much you tip
is still up to
you